question.
I always forget
How are you?
>> Good.
Take a trip.
Sorry.
There you go.
That was awesome.
Heat. Heat.
I love you.
Hello. Hello. Hi everyone. It's so good
to see your faces in here and welcome to
those of you who are joining us online.
I'm so glad you're here to celebrate the
resurrection uh with us tonight at the
table. My name is Karen Miner. My
pronouns are she, her. And uh whether
you've been here for a long time or this
is your first time or you haven't been
here often, you are welcome here. You
are welcome to be fully yourself. And I
hope this service is a blessing to you.
I have just a couple of announcements
for you.
All right. on April 19th. That will be
our next welcome to the table class. If
you are new to the table, this is an
opportunity to learn about our
community, our values, our mission, and
to ask any questions you may have about
us. Uh to celebrate this special day
today for Easter, we are going to have a
catered meal immediately following the
service in the family life center.
That's the building in the very back of
this property. Uh it will be dinner
thanks to Olive Garden, which sounds
delicious. Um we hope all of you will be
able to join us for that. We will also
have our traditional Easter egg hunt. Uh
due to the weather that has been moved
indoors, so parents, you're welcome.
You're not going to come home with muddy
feet because of the uh or shoes because
of the the weather. Um we'll have more
instructions on that later. uh for the
welcome to the table class or for any
other announcements or things going on
here at the table. There's a QR code up
on the screen. You are welcome to scan
that and see what's going on at the
table.
As we begin,
I invite you to sit comfortably.
Feel yourself be present in this moment.
You can close your eyes if you're
comfortable doing that.
Let's take a deep breath in
and out.
One more time. In
These candles behind me are a symbol of
the mystery of the loving presence of
Christ among us. A mystery that we do
not control or contain, but rather one
that meets us in our unknowing
and gently invites us towards healing
and wholeness.
Now we exit the world of noise, hurry
and productivity.
Now we enter the realm of silence,
stillness and simplicity.
Sacred space,
a place for prayer, worship and
adoration,
a place to behold Christ, revelation of
God,
heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you, to mend your heart. May we
find ourselves at last at home.
We're caring where we've come from,
where we are today. Um, we celebrate his
love together.
And I know a name
that can silence roaring waves. I know a
name
that can empty out a grave. I know a
name,
the only name that saves
and it's worthy of all praise. I call
you Jesus.
I call you I call you healer.
Risen and reigning forever.
Something comes out of the grave.
Every time I call you Jesus,
I call you, I call you Savior,
worthy of glory or heaven,
something comes out of the grave.
Every time I call your name,
I have a key.
With the manion of the dead, he holds a
key
in his holy nails.
He is the he
that has crushed the serpent's head.
Resurrected
I am. I call you Jesus.
I call you I call you healer.
Risen and reigning in power.
Something comes out of the grave.
Every time I call you Jesus,
I call you. I call you savior.
Worthy of glory forever.
Something comes out of the grave.
Every time I call your name, chains
break. My bones break. Every time I call
your name, the gates of hell shake.
Every time I call your name, chains
break, drive
away. Every time I call your name, the
gates of hell shake. Every time I call
your name.
Oh.
Oh, there's nothing
better than you. Oh, there's nothing
nothing is better than you. Let's sing
that together.
Oh, there's nothing
better than you. Oh, there's nothing
nothing is better than you.
You turn mourning to dancing.
You turn beauty for ashes.
You turn shame into glory.
You're the only one who cares.
You turn mourn into dancing.
You give beauty for ashes.
You turn shame into glory.
You're the only one who can. You turn
You turn graves into.
You turn bones into armies.
You turn seas into highways.
You're the only one who can.
You're the only one who can. You're the
only one who can.
Oh, there's nothing
better than you. Oh, there's nothing
nothing is better than you.
Sing that out tonight. Oh, there's
nothing
better than you. Oh, there's nothing
nothing is better than you.
I call you Jesus.
I call you I call you healer.
Risen and reigning in power,
something comes out of the grave.
Every time I call you Jesus,
I call you. I call you savior,
worthy of glory forever.
Something comes out of the grave
every time I call your name.
We invite you guys to join us for our
prayers of the people. And if you've
never been here before, um we will
follow along with the words on the
screen and the parts in red. We're going
to read together and then we'll leave
space in the middle of the prayer for
you guys to offer up anything that
you're carrying into this space tonight.
Whether it's a name or a situation
that's heavy on your heart, we just want
to lift those up before a God who cares.
Before a Savior who listens and hears us
for this city of Sax, Texas, and for
every city and community and all who
live in them, we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it. We pray to you for the old
and the sick. For the widow and the
orphan, for the injured and suffering.
We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives, and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
Jennifer
separated from their families.
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace, and a deep
sense of your presence.
Amen.
My hope is built on nothing less than
Jesus. Blood and righteousness.
I dare not trust the sweetest frame, but
holy lean on Jesus name.
On Christ the solid
rock I stand. All other ground is
sinking sand.
All of the ground is sinking sand.
When darkness hides his lovely face, I
rest on his unchanging grace.
In every high and stormy gale, my anchor
holds when will not fail.
On Christ the solid
rock I stand. All other ground is
sinking sand.
All other ground is sinking sand. His
oath, his covenant,
and his blood support me in the whelming
flood.
When all around my soul gives way, he
then is all my hope and stay.
On Christ the solid
rock I stand. All other ground is
sinking sand.
All other ground is sinking sand.
All of the ground is sinking sand.
Oh.
Jesus
paid it all.
To him I owe.
Sin had left a crimson stain. He washed
it white as snow. Let's sing that out
again. Jesus paid it all.
All to him I owe.
Sin had left a crescent stain. He washed
you white as snow.
He washed it white as snow.
He washed you white as snow.
Oh, praise the one who paid my dead and
raised this life up from the dead. Oh,
praise the one who paid my dead and
raised his life up from the dead. Oh,
praise the one who paid my debt and
raises life up from the dead. Oh, praise
the one who paid my dead and raises my
from the dead.
Jesus
paid it all.
Oh, to him I owe.
Sin
has left a crimson.
>> One more time. Let's sing that together.
Jesus
paid it all.
>> To him I
sin
had left a crimson stain. He washed
you white as snow.
As I got ready for this Easter
celebration,
the words of On Christ the Solid Rock I
stand. That chorus just kept coming in
and it just kind of felt like one of
those things that was it was staying. It
wouldn't I couldn't get rid of it. It
just kept repeating over and over. And I
remembered myself being a little girl
and my grandfather was a Baptist
minister and he would sing that hymn and
I just kept hearing it.
And it's funny because through all the
changes of my faith, all the different
iterations,
in my darkest moments, on my brightest
days, the thing that has remained an
anchor is this love of a savior who laid
down his life,
this unconditional grace,
this forgiveness that keeps reaching out
over and over and calling us back home.
Jesus, thank you that your love has
remained steadfast and stable.
Thank you that it continues to chase us
down
as little children and as grown men and
women and people of God. You continue to
call us back home.
Your love continues to find us,
to recreate us, to renew us.
And it's that love that we stand on
tonight,
the love of Christ, our savior, our
healer, our hope.
God, we stand on your rock.
Thank you for being our anchor, our
foundation, and our home.
It's in Jesus name we pray.
Amen.
We're so glad you guys are with us.
Would you all turn to the people on your
right and left and say, "The peace of
Christ be with you.
Well, grace and peace.
He is risen.
>> Yeah, that's that's that's an old
tradition in the church. You can try it
again. So, I say he is risen and you
respond, "He is risen indeed." You
ready? He is risen.
>> He is risen indeed.
>> Y'all are on it. Welcome. Welcome.
Welcome to the table and uh yeah, my
name is Brett and the pastor here and
it's a joy a joy to be with you to
welcome you into this space and uh that
includes those joining us online and uh
also anyone here uh tonight who is new.
Thank you so much for having the courage
to come through those double doors and
enter into this space. I know that can
be you know a lot depending on church
backgrounds and history and such. Um, so
we're so glad that you're with us. And
also welcome to all the kiddos uh in
here with us. We like y'all. You're a
little noisy, but we like it. We're
Yeah, we're we're happy. Um, so and if
any parents, if you were confused, there
there is a nursery in case that's uh a
thing where you're kind of like I don't
know, you accidentally brought in your
baby. Like I guess there's no kids
ministry. There is a nursery because we
know those really young ones, you know,
they can all struggle a little bit, but
like especially those young ones, you so
um just know that's that's available if
you need it. Um, so let's see. Here we
are, Easter. At least Easter at the
table. And uh the title of my message uh
this Easter is a resurrection love. A
resurrection love. If you've been around
the table a while, you know we're always
talking about love. I mean, that's like
the the great theme, you know, um the
love of God in Christ. And uh so it's no
different on Easter. So, our passage is
Acts chapter 10, uh, verses 34-42.
And I'm going to be reading from the
message, uh, which is a paraphrase of
the Bible, um, by Eugene Peterson. And
so, it's it says this, Acts 10:34.
Peter fairly exploded with his good
news. It's God's own truth.
Nothing could be plainer. God plays no
favorites. It makes no difference who
you are or where you're from. If you
want God and are ready to do as he says,
the door is open. The message that he
sent to the children of Israel that
through Jesus Christ, everything is
being put back together again. Well,
he's doing it everywhere among everyone.
You know the story of what happened in
Judea. It began in Galilee after John
preached a total life change. Then Jesus
arrived from Nazareth. Anointed by God
with the Holy Spirit, ready for action.
He went through the country helping
people, healing everyone who was beaten
down by the devil. He was able to do all
this because God was with him. And we
saw it. We saw it all. everything he did
in the land of the Judeans in Jerusalem
where they killed him, hung him from a
cross.
But in three days, God had him up alive
out where he could be seen. Not everyone
saw him. He wasn't put on public
display. Witnesses had been carefully
handpicked by God beforehand. us. We
were the ones there to eat and drink
with him after he came back from the
dead. He commissioned us to announce
this in public to bear solemn witness
that he is in fact the one whom God
destined as judge of the living and
dead.
So there's I mean there's so much to
love about this passage, this paraphrase
by Jean Peterson. Um I I think if I kind
of had to sum it up, I would say um this
this text, it kind of captures, doesn't
it, the the kind of relentless energy
and optimism and joy that the disciples
had that first Easter? Did you kind of
pick that up? I mean, it's not super
subtle. I mean, you see it right from
the opening words. Peter fairly exploded
with his good news. Not subtle.
Peter is pumped, right? He's he's
bursting. He's overflowing with energy
and passion for the goodness of God. He
just witnessed, by the way, the context
here is he just witnessed that the the
spirit was poured out on uh the
Gentiles, uh the non-Jews. And this was
like to him absolutely, he couldn't
believe it. Like people didn't have to,
you know, eat kosher and like follow the
rules and do the thing like just all of
a sudden God's just like willy-nilly
just doing whatever God wants, you know,
just being poured out on all people. and
he's like freaking out. He's like, "Oh
my gosh, he just can't believe it,
right? The way that the outsiders have
become the insiders.
So, so why are we so busy trying to
create more outsiders?" You know, this
let's kind of skip ahead the message.
So, we'll keep we'll stay here. He just
It's like Peter gets it, right? He sees
it. He sees the implications of the
resurrection that God in Christ has
brought life from death and it's a life
for everyone. He he understands that
through Jesus Christ everything is being
put back together as he says in verse
36.
Now you might wonder like what what does
that mean? Like everything's being put
back together and it's kind of Bible
language or something. Uh I mean I think
he means it quite literally like I mean
I don't have to convince you probably
that so much about humanity
and the cosmos just seems broken right
as Romans 8 describes all creation is
groaning longing for the day of its
redemption
longing for resurrection.
I mean, just watch the nightly news or
if you don't do that anymore, just turn
on your social, you know, the the
Instagram or Tik Tok or whatever your
your social media preference is, you
know, just just scroll a little bit. Uh,
you'll see it, right? It's it's a I
mean, basically the political, the
religious, the social worlds, they're
just they just churn, don't they? It's
like constant crisis and upheaval.
It is certainly a Good Friday kind of
world. In other words, a crossbuilding,
crossbearing
kind of world, right? And and that's not
something Jesus story, the Jesus story
kind of, you know, sidesteps or moves
around like, no, no, no, it's not a
small group of like just a few bad
people who put Jesus on the cross for
some reason. Like, no, that's not the
way the New Testament frames it. It's
it's the crowd. In other words, us. It's
the politicians. It's the religious
leaders. I mean, heck, even most of
Jesus' disciples don't come away from
Good Friday looking good, looking put
together, looking faithful.
And yet, that's precisely the point,
right? That that's that's exactly it.
Like, this is the beauty of of how
Christ like died and then shows up on
Easter morning, right? Christ dies not
with and this will become important
later not with a word of bitterness on
his lips you know how could you you know
no what does he die what's some of his
last words father forgive them
forgive them for they do not know what
they are doing
and and in resurrection what what what
does he say what what's the the words on
his lips like and and how does he come
back he's he's this perfect embod
embodiment, expression, and just a
revelation
of 1 John 4:18. There is no fear in
love. A but perfect love. What does it
do? It just drives out. It drives out
fear. And and that's what Christ does. I
mean, you'll recall after his
resurrection, he he calls the disciples
by name. He calls them brother and
sister and friend. some of his first
kind of terms of phrase, it's things
like um rejoice,
peace be with you, don't be afraid.
You see, Easter is when the church
realized that God is better than we ever
thought possible.
And so it seems to me like as the church
we have this wonderful
opportunity
to just declare to the world like, "Hey,
good news.
Christ is risen. Death does not have the
final word. You are loved. You are seen.
God is for you, not against you."
Yes, humanity is kind of the worst, but
but God's heart towards us in that is
always one of unrelenting grace and
forgiveness and love
and and the church like we have the
opportunity to express this not only
with words. I mean, Lord knows the
church has said a lot of words the last
few thousand years.
We have the opportunity in our actions
to express this great love. In fact, you
might have caught it. I so appreciate
that little verse in uh Acts 10 that we
just read where Peter summarizes the
ministry of Jesus.
Did you catch that part? It's like such
a small little line, but so significant.
You had to sum up like the the the work
of Jesus in the world in just like a
sentence. You know, how would you do it?
This is how Peter does it. He says this.
This is verse 38. He went through the
country helping people
and healing everyone who was beat down
by the devil. I love that. Like
sometimes we get like very I think
twisted into knots over, you know, like
what's my purpose? What's my calling? Am
I in the will of God? You know, like we
get very worried about this. And uh I
mean I think honestly this verse this is
a good this is a good summation. Like
what's the Christian's calling? That
that's a I mean that's a darn good life,
right? What's my calling? I go around
helping people, right? That's that's
beautiful.
Helping everyone who's been beat down by
life in the devil. You see, I think the
world is not waiting for Christians who
are right. It is waiting for Christians
who are free. Free enough to love like
the risen one. The one who went about
doing good to all. church. That's our
calling. That's our mission. Peter is
pumped. I am pumped. Are you pumped?
>> You're pump. All right. Perfect.
Here's the problem. I want you in your
mind's eye to right now just kind of
envision the broader church in America.
And I want you to just kind of ask
yourself, are we known for going about
doing good to all
that like brand Christianity? You know,
are we a are we known as a non- anxious
people?
Non- anxious and free.
Free enough to love like the risen one
as we just said. You know, sadly, when I
see so much of the church right now,
what I see it's it's almost as though we
are trapped forever in Good Friday.
We're just kind of hanging out there
in in essence like what I see are a
people whether real or imagined I
suspect mostly imagined that we we kind
of feel ourselves to be under attack
agrieved betrayed marginalized and
assaulted. It's almost like we identify
again not with a Christ of the Gospels,
but a sort of imagined Christ, a a
Christ who we kind of somehow remember
as I alluded to earlier as dying with
words of bitterness on his lips instead
of words of forgiveness. A and almost an
imagined Christ that we somehow think he
resurrected in a fury at the world.
You know, there's no better recent
expression of this than the film Wake Up
Dead Man, a Knives Out Mystery, written
and directed by Ryan Johnson. Um, it it
is PG-13. It has some language and
violence. Um, so it's not I would not
say it's kid-friendly, but if you're
like adult and you're a Christian, like
you should watch this film. I mean, it's
absolutely uh just incredible.
And uh it's a it's a murder mystery. But
really the the question kind of driving
the film is is not so much like you know
who done it, who's killed the guy, you
know, whatever. Um the the main question
is really uh who is the church and will
we be a force for love in this world
or will we just mirror back to the world
its anxieties and fears?
The answer to that question is framed by
two priests. Monsenor Wixs played by
Joshua Brolan the one there in that
image on the right and uh Josh O'Conor
um and that Father Jud played by Josh
Okconor. Now Monser Wixs he represents
uh kind of I don't know almost like the
dark side of like religion and Christian
faith. It is pretty bleak. He's very
furious at the sins of the world. You
know the so-called backsliders
in his congregation. and his sermons are
like deeply tribal and he kind of has
that knack for like zeroing in on
someone that he kind of sees like they
don't fit in this community and then
like kind of morphing the sermon to like
focus in on them and like drive them
away. You know, whether it was like in
in the film he like blasts, you know,
like queer folks or like single mothers
like just all sorts of weird and he's
kind of constantly doing this. But, you
know, even beyond the way he kind of
focuses on individuals, what I found
most fascinating about him as a
character is kind of his um the way he
understands the church as a lone island
in the world and but the world is like
in in a sea of sin.
Here's some of his exact words. And I
want you to kind of notice the illusions
here to the the crucifixion death of
Christ. He says this, "Pierced,
murdered, left in a hold of rot to be
forgotten."
As with our savior, so with the church.
Our church is assailed by wicked
modernity by the enemies of God. The
vermin who would oppress in silence and
bar us from our rightful place as the
rulers of a Christian nation. And I
stand before you as a warrior of Christ
in the armor of God, ready to fight the
world to my last breath.
There's so much capture. It just
captures so much of the church today.
Agrieved, offended, embittered,
fancfully imagining that somehow Christ
joins us in that.
In Father Jud, though, we see a very a
very different character. Thanks be to
God. I was honestly blown away. I
couldn't believe like such a positive
portrayal of um a priest in this film.
He's um I would say he kind of expresses
this like beautiful faith. He's a he's
like a young priest, very idealistic in
you know many ways um but you know pure
pure in heart and he genu genuinely
embodies that spirit of Christ which
went around doing good. He's like you
know just kind of the the picture of who
the church is truly called to be. And I
really do mean the whole church, not
just like priests and pastors or
leaders. I mean like literally all of
us. In fact, um like he has no interest
in, you know, fighting culture wars and
such. There's this um scene where a
bishop towards the beginning of the film
is inviting him to this parish,
whatever, but he needs to make sure he's
kind of on the same page. You know, so
the the bishop says this to Jud. He
says, "We need fighters today,
but to fight the worlds, not ourselves.
A priest is a shepherd. The world is a
wolf."
And Father Jud responds, it's so
interesting. He says this, "No,
I don't believe that, father."
Respectfully, you start fighting wolves
and before you know it, everyone you
don't understand is a wolf.
Christ came to heal the world, not fight
it. I believe that. And then he says,
"It's this,
not this."
You know,
I love that Father Jud's preaching the
gospel. It's a beautiful faith. The
wonderful author and Christian Maline
Lingle summed it up beautifully. She
said, "We draw people to Christ not by
loudly discrediting what they believe by
telling them how wrong they are and how
right we are, but by showing them a
light that is so lovely that they want
with all their hearts to know the source
of it."
Oh my gosh, isn't that what the world
needs
in a cross shattered world? Isn't
humanity just longing for Christians
marked by a resurrection love?
Isn't the world waiting not for
Christians who are right, but for
Christians who are free?
free enough to love
to go about doing good to all.
Now, you might ask though, what does
that look like though? You know, what
does that look like in life? I think
often people feel a little bit
disqualified. You know, they feel like
uh I just don't have the theological
knowledge, the right training, the right
gifting. You know, maybe you think to
yourself like, I'm no good on a
microphone. I got no charisma, no social
media following. my little social media
follow like 12 people in my grandma. You
know, I got no influence. What am I
supposed to do? Here's the thing,
though. You know what? The church has
had about 2,000 years of trying all that
power, influence, more microphones,
more, you know, charisma. Like, such a
mixed bag. I mean, some some good
moments, you know, mostly a bunch of
like not good, you know, hasn't been
great.
See, because that's never been like the
best expression of God's love, has it?
What's what's the best expression? I'll
I'll put it like this. I think the best
kept secret of love is that it's not
primarily your smarts or your charisma
or your giftedness that God uses to heal
another. What is it? It is your loving
attention and presence.
In fact, one of the more moving scenes
of Wake Up Dead Man, I'll close with
this story. I know the kids are going to
be getting restless soon if they're not
already. Um, there's a moment in the
film where uh, Father Jud, he's
anxiously trying to uh, gather evidence
to clear his name because uh, the whole
town, everyone basically thinks he's the
murderer. And so he's like kind of
freaking out, you know, he's making
calls all these like county clerks and
trying to get records and and you know,
all this stuff. And uh so he places a
call and at one point he's kind of
rushing this receptionist on the phone
for information
when she learns that like oh he's you
know he's a he's a priest he's a pastor
and so she asks him for prayer
and it's so beautiful just immediately
he just stops his line of questioning he
just stops
and he listens and she begins to explain
that her mother is extremely ill. Their
relationship is fractured
and she begins to weep and and Judge
just stays with her there on the phone
just listening,
prays for her,
points her to God.
I think church like it's as simple as
that. That's it. That's what people
need. We don't need more fighters, do
we?
This Easter, we don't need more
fighters.
No, we need more Peters. We need more
Juds, more folks committed to just going
out doing good to all.
May this Easter inspire us to be that
kind of presence in people's lives.
In the name of the Father, the Son, and
the Holy Spirit. Amen.
So
if you attend the table regularly then
uh you know that up until this day we've
been in this this season of Lent this
kind of heart and mind preparation uh
for the Easter season and uh Lent it
kicks off with a service called Ash
Wednesday where traditionally people uh
come forward at the end of that service
and receive the the sign of the cross in
dust and ashes on their forehead. And
often in some traditions the the priest
or the pastor will even say from dust
you came to dust you return.
But tonight to mark the end of the e of
the linton season in the beginning of
the Easter season uh we wanted to invite
you forward uh to receive a kind of
Easter blessing um to remember this
moment that that you've been invited
into resurrection life uh by Christ. And
so instead of, you know, a cross and
dust and ashes, you'll receive um a
circle on your forehead or the back of
your hand if you'd prefer uh of olive
oil and lavender um just symbolizing the
empty tomb and the resurrection of uh of
Jesus. So the way we'll go about this is
very similar to how we tend to do
communion. Um except today we're going
to form kind of two lines. So, we'll
still go rowby row, but um I'll be over
here. My wife Maggie will be over here,
and uh we're just going to kind of
welcome folks forward. We'll still go
kind of front row first and and so on.
Um but, uh there will be two lines for
you to jump into so we can go a little
bit quicker. And uh also just know this
time is open to everyone. Maybe you're
here and you're like, uh not sure if you
have the right beliefs or the right
denominational background or whatever.
uh just know if you want to participate
and receive this blessing, connect with
Christ in this way, um then you are uh
free to do that. So I'm going to pray uh
and then I'll invite you forward to uh
to receive that that blessing.
Lord Jesus,
set us free.
Set us free from bitterness.
Set us free from hatred.
Set us free from fear.
May we be a resurrection people, a
people whose love even the grave cannot
hold down.
May this next year find us doing good to
all people in the name of the
resurrected Christ.
Amen.
If you guys would stand with us again,
we're going to close out this um time
together with an old hymn called Because
He Lives. Um so if you know it, please
join in. And if not, just enjoy this
song.
God sent his son.
They called him Jesus.
He came to love,
heal, and forgive.
He bled and died
to buy my pardon.
An empty grave is there to prove my
Savior lives.
Because he lives,
I can face tomorrow.
Because he lives.
All fear is gone
because I know
he holds the future
and life is worth living just because he
lives.
How sweet to hold
our newborn baby
and feel the pride
and joy he gives.
But greater still
the calm assurance
this child can face uncertain day
because Christ lives.
Because he lives.
I can face tomorrow
because he lives.
All fear is gone
because I know
he holds the future.
And life is worth living just because he
lives.
And then one day
I'll cross that river.
I'll fight life's final
war with me.
In this death
gives way to victory.
I'll see the lights of glory and I'll
know he reigns.
>> Because he lives.
I can face tomorrow
because he lives.
All fear is gone
because I know
he holds the future.
And life is worth living just because he
lives.
And life is worth the living just
because he lives.
Thank you so much worship team for
preparing the music so beautifully.
Again, thank you all so much for joining
us here tonight and to those watching
online.
If you're interested in joining a small
group, attending a table event,
supporting the table financially, or if
you're new and would be willing to fill
out a visitor card so we have a record
of your visit, you can take any of those
steps by scanning the QR code that's up
on the screens behind me. We also have
uh physical cards over on the credenza
to my left and you could just put them
in the the wooden box on the right of
the credenza as you leave tonight. Keep
in mind because we met tonight and
celebrated Easter, there will be no
service tomorrow on Sunday. So, please
don't show up because we won't be here.
Um don't forget that immediately
following the service tonight, we are
providing a meal for everyone in the
family life center. It's the building at
the back of the property. You can just
go out these double doors and go down
the long hallway to the end of the
building and there's a walkway or you
can just follow all the people that will
go be going towards the food. Um,
everyone is welcome to attend that and
we hope you will. It's such a fun time
to speak to everyone, get to know new
people, and share a meal together. Our
kids ministry team will be busy setting
up for the egg hunt while everyone eats.
And we'll come gather all the kiddos
together from there as soon as they are
ready.
Kids, are you about ready? That's going
to be super fun. And thank you to all
the kids ministry volunteers for putting
that together.
All right. Yeah. Thank you.
We love our kids ministry volunteers and
all of our kiddos.
>> And now let me send you into your week
with this blessing.
You can hold out your hands in a posture
to receive or you can just open up your
heart to these words that I believe are
true
for each and every one of you.
You are a child of God.
You are a child of God. This is true on
your best day and it's true on your
worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between, go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved, you are worthy, and you are
accepted
just as you are.
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with. Be blessed.
Don't forget to go eat. We have Olive
Garden waiting for us. And remember, we
won't see you tomorrow, but we'll see
you a week from tomorrow on the 12th.
Happy Easter. You are loved. Good night.
Because he lives,
I can face tomorrow.
all fear is gone.
Because I know
he holds a future
and life is worth living just because he
lives.
His life is worth the living just
because he lives.